buongiorno
bene adesso che ci che vi siete
presentati adesso se volete mi presento
io l'ho già fatto in parte però io
voglio dirvi qualcosa di più chiaramente
sono studenti 19 anni sono nato qui a
trento
frequento il primo anno di studi
internazionali
qui all'università studio perché
chiaramente c'è tanta studiare
intendiamoci però ho tanti hobby mio
preferito allo sport qualsiasi tipo di
sport
il migliore direi che mio preferito è la
pallavolo
l'ho praticato per nove anni ad alti
livelli adesso chiaramente non ho più il
tempo per portarci dietro le temporale
semplici però trovo ancora il tempo per
andare in palestra e allenare una
piccola squadra di ragazzi under 15
il calcio è il calcio è qualcosa di
fondamentale a partita del venerdì con
gli amici è qualcosa di sacro non
bisogna mancare poi mi capite vero
immaginavo
e poi qui siamo a trento in mezzo alle
montagne in mezzo alle dolomiti
quindi non amare le montagne sarebbe un
delitto e quindi anche la montagna
vado a far scalate scio c'è anche
scialpinismo mi piace muovermi
tutte cose bellissime no c'è un però un
piccolo però che per fare tutte queste
cose serve fiato e io di fiato torneo
maglione o meno perché io ho la fibrosi
cistica cosa più realistica ma non
chiederete figura il cistica una
malattia genetica alla malattia genetica
che compromette in maniera seria
all'apparato digerente e respiratorio
in pratica tutte le secrezioni del corpo
tutti i liquidi che produciamo sono più
densi e più concentrati il sudore più
salato le lacrime sono più dense i
succhi gastrici
c'è una frase molto importante che
risale al 1700 quando ancora c'erano
delle osservazioni empiriche su questa
malattia
poi per il bambino che sapora di salato
da un bacio sulla fronte
perché maledetto e presto deve morire
una condanna senza appello sarei dire
ovviamente le cose sono cambiate e
vedete sono qua a parlare di fronte a
voi non sono nè deperito né altro no
sono in forma dai ci sta concedetemelo
almeno questo a un certo punto un nostro
amico qualche estate fa viene a
chiederci ma vuoi scalare il
kilimangiaro e di quel kilimangiaro java
così alto
io metto informiamoci cos'è questo
kilimangiaro chi mangia rowe è la più
alta montagna dell'africa uno strato
vulcano in fase di quiescenza contrae
coni vulcanici altre 5.895 metri è la
montagna più alta dell'africa
il vulcano più alto del mondo la
montagna si in copia al 3 del mondo e
una delle seven summit del pianeta
al che io fibrosi cistica sul
kilimangiaro
no dai non prendiamoci in giro
ovviamente la mia famiglia inizialmente
java che cosa si salta in testa poi dopo
hanno capito
bisogna far qualcosa già andare oltre
bisogna bisogna far cambiare la
mentalità
i medici non ne parliamo sono andato al
medico curante direttora io riesca nel
kilimangiaro ha sì
a seguire secondo me è meglio invece che
mai sul lido di jesolo aprenti l'aria
salubre del mare seduto lì non vi piace
indovinate come è andata ve l'ho detto
prima giustamente
e quindi a febbraio del 2000 14 siamo
sbarcati in africa e l'africa te la
raccontano
ti dicono tante cose però fino a quando
non ci arrivi non sai veramente come i
primi giorni siamo abbiamo camminato
tanto in mezzo agli animali della savana
in mezzo alla giungla
non vi dico altro durante la nostra
traversata della giungla c'era una
pioggia battente 99 per cento di umidità
il fango sotto la pioggia sopra insomma
un disastro
però voi romano camminando
siamo arrivati fino in cima a tre 3008
al primo rifugio poi a 4800 secondo
rifugio e vogliamo dare l'assalto la
cina e la notte dell'assalto alla cina è
stata una cosa pazzesca sveglia a
mezzanotte per arrivare in cima alle 6
di mattina in una nebbia padana
sembra di essere lo svincolo della iv mi
sono trovato questo cartello verde che
diceva congratulazioni
sei arrivato in cima al kilimangiaro ho
pianto non è un sentimento umano e poi
la discesa mi aspettavano altre undici
ore per arrivare al rifugio dove avremo
dormito
fate conto partenza mezzanotte arriva al
rifugio alle 17 17 ore di camminata al
netto
ed è ed è andata e dai così perché tutto
questo è stato possibile
voglio dire eravamo rimasti al bambino
che saprà chi sapeva di salato e che
presto doveva morire e adesso mandiamo
un ragazzo ma ti pubblicistiche sul
kilimangiaro
la ricerca ha fatto passi da gigante nel
1989 che clinicamente parlando all'altro
ieri hanno scoperto la proteina causa
della febbre cistica cftr questa
proteina sostanzialmente zoppa nel senso
che non permette al corpo di funzionare
bene ora un piccolo inciso su quella che
è la ricerca cosa ricerca sono tre tipi
di ricerca la prima che potremmo
chiamare la terapia genica come molti
hanno definita ha alimentato tante
speranze per quanto riguarda la fibrosi
cistica male male ha deluso la seconda è
quella che ci immaginiamo tutti lo
scienziato pazzo con i fumi gli
alambicchi questi diversi liquidi
colorati quello che ci immaginiamo tutti
e poi c'è una terza figura figlia di
quello che è il progresso scientifico
io lo chiamo scienziato metereologo
perché il meterologo guarda le correnti
le nubi in pratica cc da un'idea di come
sarà la giornata
da qui ha molto tempo anche una
settimana due settimane in pratica lo
scienziato metereologo fa la stessa cosa
con la cellula dice se a cellula
sottoposto ad un dato trattamento
reagisce in questo modo è plausibile che
ci siano tutta una serie di conseguenze
in pratica da allo scienziato pazzo di
concreto su cui lavorare non andare a
tentoni
come dicevo nei tanti atleta storico
fino come poteva essere 10 20 anni fa
questo ha premesso alla ricerca medica
di raggiungere livelli tifino
a neanche 34 anni fa sarebbero stati
possibili
la prima volta è stato scoperto è stata
prodotta diciamo un mix vitaminico
apposta per la fibrosi cistica
adesso la ricerca medica e scientifica
che sta concentrando sul
sugli antibiotici e non più in vena per
3 4 ore attaccati a un letto ma
semplicemente inalando un piccolo buffet
sostanzialmente quello che vorrei dirvi
oggi è che il coraggio di osare e anche
questo è la battere il leaf meter
oggi si giocano i giochi importanti
passatemi la ripetizione oggi per la
prima volta nella storia dell'uomo
abbiamo la possibilità di battere la
malattia genetica in assoluto più
diffusa al mondo è una sfida alla quale
non ci possiamo tirare indietro
no signori
e questa la sfida molto più alta della
scalata del kilimangiaro la ricerca
costa fatica soprattutto siete con me
siamo tutti insieme proiettati verso
questa ricerca medico scientifica
allora arriveremo molto presto alla
soluzione grazie